hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel this is your host YouTube's
favorite power bottom Jordan uh with
that being said let's go ahead and get
back into some systems design with all
the layoffs going on as I've covered
plenty in this channel uh and view horde
of course uh you know it is a great time
to get studying and go ahead and get
really good at this content so that you
can you know pass your interviews in the
future so today we'll be talking about
read committed isolation a topic that I
personally have been putting off as uh
to quote my ex-girlfriend I am scared of
commitment so let's go ahead and get
into it alrighty so let's go ahead and
get into the iPad portion of this video
so the subject of today's content is
read committed isolation so before we
can actually go ahead and get into what
that means let's talk about databases a
little bit so in the past we've
mentioned the databases are
multi-threaded and so effectively what
multi-threaded means is that we have a
bunch of reader threads a bunch of
writer threads basically a bunch of
concurrent executions have happening on
the same computer and so we don't
actually know the order of those
executions and as a result of that we
can have a lot of issues that basically
threaten the correctness of our results
so as you can see in My Graph here you
know in time one we would have a writer
thread time two we would have a reader
thread going time three we have a
different reader thread but the point is
because all of these are being sent at
around the same time there's not really
any good way for us to know exactly
what's being written first and then
what's being read I mean this could
happen in a completely different order
and so we don't know about the
legitimacy of our results it's really
hard to tell and so we need to go ahead
and put in some precautions so basically
what this does is it introduces a lot of
race conditions so before we uh you know
talk about some examples of race
conditions that we might see in a
database I just want to introduce some
terminology which I've kind of mentioned
in the past but let's go ahead and make
it official so this concept is actually
going to be the word commit committing a
right basically just means that you know
the right is confirmed in the database
for example if we have a sequence of
Rights you know I'm writing in one row
and then I'm writing in a second row
those two rights are only committed when
both of them are successful right so if
I've written in the first row but I
haven't yet written in the second we
know that that first right is not yet
committed so they have to all be
finished
okay so let's talk about some examples
of race conditions and so the first one
is going to be called the dirty right
so the dirty right while it sounds like
a sex position is not in fact it's
something that happens in databases so
let's imagine we have two threads right
we've got T1 and T2 that stands for
Threads not time and then the time axis
is actually going to be going down this
way so as you can see as we go down
that's kind of the order of what
operations are happening so imagine we
have basically two different rows on our
database maybe two tables in the
database and one row from each one is
going to be our you know bath water
table and then the other is going to be
our delivery addresses table for example
you know great and great example right
so our bathwater.purchaser uh T1 is
basically me right
I am going to go ahead and try and
purchase some bath water so I'm setting
the purchaser to Jordan at the same time
our former president Donald Trump is
also trying to purchase the same
bathwater we have similar taste in women
and so he is going to go ahead and set
bathwater.purchases to Donald makes
sense similarly though his right is
reaching the database faster than mine
so now he has address dot delivery water
is the white house because that's where
he wants it sent to and I of course want
it sent to your mom's house at T4 so
basically our rights go ahead and get
interleaved even though my right of I
guess technically got there first he was
able to get both rights done before I
could and then we're both committing at
time five so now what ends up happening
basically is as a result of this dirty
right we see that um you know the the
purchases bro has Donald set as the
value so this one wins and then as far
as the delivery water goes because you
know Donald was after Jordan as far as
the delivery water goes your mom's house
wins over the White House so now we have
inconsistent results out of our database
and effectively what a dirty right is is
when writing
over
uncommitted values
so in this case as you can see none of
our rights had actually committed and we
just wrote over them and so the problem
with that is that we can then get in
this inconsistent State and that is
going to break some invariance of our
database so how can we actually go ahead
and think about fixing a dirty right
well what would work really nicely is
something like locking so if you're not
familiar locking basically just means
that you know if I have the lock on a
certain row no one else can do anything
with that row right they have to be able
to grab the lock but they can't until I
release it so let's imagine this one is
me this one is Donald
and then you know we're both trying to
grab two rows to write to them so let's
imagine first I grab the lock now I have
it Donald says okay well I'm gonna go
ahead and try to do the same thing
because I want to write
guess what buddy you can't I already
have it so that's not gonna work now you
might say oh well Jordan what if he
grabs row number two and then you try
and grab row number two and then you
know now you're in a deadlock because
neither one is going to release either
of the locks and effectively we both
want each other's resources and we're
never gonna give them up well I would
argue that one solution is you could
just grab the rows in the same order the
database could somehow decide The
Ordering of the rows or if worse comes
to worst you could do some sort of
Deadlock detection which is a thing in
you know some kind of pieces of Hardware
like databases where they'll actually
look for resources in deadlock and if
that's the case they'll have to make one
of those transactions give up its locks
okay so row level locks are basically
how we go ahead and fix dirty rights
which is writing over uncommitted data
however dirty rights are not the only
issue that we're talking about today
another one is dirty reads so again
we've got two transactions where the
vertical axis is going to be time sorry
for my crappy arrows
so in this case basically we've got
transaction one which is me removing ten
dollars from my balance because I have
bought more foot pictures from Karina
cop in transaction two you know maybe
it's me checking my bank account balance
and seeing that I am ten dollars down
right similarly now Karina cough is
going to be receiving 10 more dollars
but what if the right to karinikov
receiving 10 more dollars fails for
example who knows maybe her bank account
is now invalid or you know she was
laundering a ton of money and now her
account has just been deactivated the
issue now is that I have gone ahead and
read an uncommitted right right because
Jordan balance minus ten dollars was not
actually yet committed the commit
happens down here because the commit
only happens once both of these rights
go through and since the Karina cop one
failed I've now read an incommitted uh
or not in committed but uncommitted
right and so basically a dirty read is
reading
God I can't spell today
uncommitted
data and obviously that's a problem
because now if I'm reading my bank
account balance I think that I lost ten
dollars but I still don't have my foot
pictures and so that is obviously going
to be an issue so how can we go ahead
and fix dirty reads well there are a
couple of options
the first one is we could do row level
locking like what we did before right
let's scroll back up here I could do row
level locks because I would have to grab
the relevant Row in order to basically
read it but I couldn't read it yet
because someone else had it locked
because they were writing that row
however that's kind of a pain in the ass
the reason being that locking is slow
and if we can avoid having locks that is
very good because it means that anytime
we're writing something all of the other
threads trying to read it are going to
be unable to do so and they are going to
get bottlenecks significantly reads are
much faster than rights and as a result
you know one slow right can slow down a
ton of reads and so it would be much
better if we could just avoid using
locks in general
so basically the fix here is that we
want to store the old value until the
commit right so let's imagine my bank
account old value was 100 then I buy
those foot pictures so we've got new at
90 and then the second Karina cop
gets hers uh to a plus 10 then we switch
that pointer over to new and now guess
what we're reading from this value so
this is how we're able to do this we
just have to store an extra value and
this way even though we're incurring a
little bit more storage overhead we are
greatly decreasing the amount of locks
that we have to wait on and speeding up
our database significantly so again
that's why I have this right over here
could use locking but much more
expensive we shouldn't be doing that so
ultimately I've now covered two types of
race conditions right we've got our
dirty Reeds right here and then
scrolling all the way up we've got our
dirty rights so basically ultimately any
database that is going to protect
against both dirty reads and dirty
rights is one that is implementing read
committed isolation and so now you know
what that term means basically the point
is if we're protecting against those two
this database is considered to be read
committed however we should note that
there are many more rage conditions than
just the ones that I've outlined in this
video and in subsequent videos we're
going to go ahead and talk about those
there are basically you know others that
are even more pesky and harder to catch
and so the databases that do protect
against those obviously have to use more
complex Solutions we'll talk about those
in the future videos and I will see you
guys next time